if you were asked what is the most
turbulent region in the world what would
you answer Latin America or sub-Saharan
Africa it's hard to pin down because if
there's one thing that abounds in the
world it is conflict however another
perfectly logical answer could be the
Middle East possibly the region with the
most clashes per square mile on the
planet think about it at this meeting
point between Europe Asia and Africa we
have Israel's conflict with Palestine
jihadist terrorism Isis the Syrian Civil
War Kurdish Independence the problem
with the Muslim Brotherhood and the war
in Yemen not forgetting of course we
also have the mother of all conflicts
the fanatical confrontation between the
Shiites and the sunnis and okay I know
what many of you are thinking here they
go again talking about the divisions
within Islam well no relax this video is
not about Islam and its frat residual
infighting well it is in part but not
directly in this video we are going to
deal with something that for many is
representing a tectonic shift in global
geopolitics the growing ties between
China and this region and you might be
wondering what does China have to do
with the Middle East well it's certainly
not that Xi Jinping wants to go
sightseeing on a camel or anything close
to that but rather with news stories
like like this one 11th of March 2023
Chinese broke a deal up ends mid-east
diplomacy and challenges us indeed China
has managed to close a deal to bring
Iran and Saudi Arabia two of the great
powers in the Middle East that have been
at each other's throats for much of
their history closer together and you
know what this means
foreign
is continuing to spread its tentacles in
this part of the world Pakistan is no
longer enough now it wants to go further
and Target the heavyweights directly and
logically Saudi Arabia and Iran are too
heavyweights with one huge Advantage
they can guarantee China's energy Supply
that is why we should not be surprised
to find news items like these Saudi
Arabia says 50 billion Investments
agreed with China Saudi aramco boosts
China investment with two Refinery deals
now to what extent is the Middle East
becoming another backyard for China
could this be a blow to U.S interests
how far will relations between the
Saudis and Iranians go today we're going
to answer all of these questions but
first first we need to look at some
history
[Music]
like cats and dogs
yes historically there have been many
tensions over religion Shiite Islam
versus Sunni Islam however by and large
had never went any farther than that nor
after the 4 formation in 1932 of Saudi
Arabia as we know it today or the
arrival of Iran's palavi Dynasty in
1925. what's more after the second world
war and during the Cold War both
countries were under the umbrella of the
Western Bloc they had shared interests
both were close allies of the United
States however in 1979 suddenly
everything changed Iran's Islamic
revolution had begun
as you know in 1979 Ayatollah kameni LED
their now well-known Islamic revolution
in Iran he promoted a message against
the monarchies of the Persian Gulf and
sought to expand the revolution wherever
Shiite minorities were to be found and
can you guess where a significant Shiite
Community is located precisely in the
east of Saudi Arabia which is exactly
where the largest oil fields of this
country are located with this in mind it
is no wonder that Riyadh suspicion and
distrust of Tehran multiplied precisely
for this region the Saudi Government
tried to weaken the Revolution by all
means for example when the Iran Iraq war
broke out Riad did not hesitate in
financing the Iraqi regime with tens of
billions of dollars during the eight
years of the war in addition in 1981 it
led the founding of the gulf cooperation
Council an umbrella Organization for all
the absolute monarchies of the Persian
Gulf
and so things went between the two
powers from bad to worse however in 1997
the moderate Muhammad katami became
president of Iran and relations
stabilized for a few years in 2001 the
two countries even managed to sign a
security pact to fight terrorism however
this renewed stability did not last long
either it all blew up with a fresh
conflict in the Middle East let's take a
look
[Music]
raising the temperature
2003 was a particularly turbulent year
thousands of angry protesters took the
streets in the United States Europe and
the United Kingdom why you guessed it
the invasion of Iraq despite not having
the support of the United Nations
security Council Washington and London
went to war against Saddam Hussein for
allegedly having weapons of mass
destruction you have all heard about
that already they didn't what you might
not know is that this Invasion turned
the tense relationship between the Arabs
and Iranians even more Upside Down The
Invasion provoked nothing less than the
beginning of a particular cold war
between these two countries at stake was
political and even military Supremacy
don't forget that Iraq is a key country
in the Middle East with more than 40
million inhabitants it is one of the
most heavily populated countries in the
world it has the fifth largest crude oil
reserves in the world and also has
important Water Resources thanks to the
Tigris and Euphrates rivers to top it
all off just look at this map Iraq is
located right at the heart of the region
and borders turkey Syria Jordan Saudi
Arabia and Kuwait in other words with a
rack on its side Tehran would become the
dominant power in the Middle East and
you know what that's exactly what
started to happen after the overthrow of
Saddam Hussein and the power vacuum that
was created in the country Iraq's Shiite
majority backed by the Iran of the
ayatollahs found the perfect breeding
round for consolidating and extending
its power for example Nuri al-maliki
began ruling Iraq in 2006 and yes
al-maliki was the leader of the country
but the truth is that he only had eyes
for the Shiite community so the conflict
was on
[Applause]
and keep in mind that the Cold War
didn't stop with Iraq not at all Tehran
saw its chance so suddenly the Iranian
regime started supporting a lot
movements all over the Islamic World
Hezbollah and Lebanon Bashar al-assad
and Syria the revolutionaries and
Bahrain during their Arab Spring and of
course the houthis in Yemen the latter
ended up with disastrous Saudi military
intervention that has cost them a lot of
lives and money we have already covered
it here before on visualpolitik and we
haven't even reached 2016 yet what
happened in 2016. well take a look Saudi
Arabia executes Shiite reformist cleric
nimir al-nimir and 46 others on
terrorism charges as you can imagine
this is not set too well in Iran tens of
thousands of protesters took to the
streets in Tehran and even burned down
the Saudi Embassy diplomatic relations
between the two countries were
completely severed what's more there was
another important issue on the table
that separated them even further the
Iranian nuclear program
with the bomb Iran would be impregnable
of course this was not only of concern
to the Saudis this program made Iran
suddenly become one of the great
protagonists of international news
Cycles or rather one of the big villains
in international politics since it
launched its nuclear program Iran has
been hit with all kinds of sanctions
which has made it more and more isolated
from the rest of the world without going
any further this is what a spokesman for
the Biden administration's National
Security Council recently said the
United States is committed to never
allowing Iran to acquire a nuclear
weapon We Believe diplomacy is the best
way to achieve that goal but President
Biden has also been clear that we have
not taken any options off the table
National Security Council spokesperson
in remarks to the wsj in other words
Iran needed to find new partners in
visual politic viewers this is exactly
where today's great protagonist enters
the scene pay close attention to this
[Music]
what is China doing in the Middle East
China's presence in the Middle East and
North Africa is not strictly new in 1956
it had already succeeded in making Egypt
the first country in the region to
recognize the People's Republic of China
as the real China to the detriment of
Taiwan however since the arrival of Xi
Jinping the stakes have become much
clearer especially with regard to Iran
China and Iran still partnership with
25-year cooperation pact although no
details have emerged The Pact broadly
envisages Chinese Investments of around
400 billion dollars in the Iranian
energy sector however if we compare them
with the relations that China has forged
with Saudi Arabia over recent decades
Iran seems to be on a second level after
denzhou Peng came to power and opened up
to the rest of the world the Asian
Giants economy took off and do you know
what that means that China needed more
and more oil and where is the most
secure and stable supply of crude oil
exactly it's in Saudi Arabia in this way
the Saudis became beijing's key supplier
in 2022 Russia snatched the top spot
from Saudi Arabia but you all know why
that happened be that as it meme the
fact is that in recent years China has
been strengthening its relations with
both Iran and Saudi Arabia and that's
exactly what explains how Beijing
managed to finalize a deal for these two
great enemies to shake hands again as
you know a fat check can always work
miracles of course in addition to the
money the timing was also right check
this out
foreign
game changers
[Music]
after seven years of enormous tension
between Riyadh and Tehran on the 10th of
March 2023 both countries decided to
shake hands at least to restore their
diplomatic relations and let's see I
think we can all understand that when
your main client asks you for something
you are at least receptive in a way
that's what has happened between Saudi
Arabia and China this time however
dollars are not the only reason after
all China needs Saudi Arabia more than
the Arab country needs the Asian giant
if China were to reduce its purchase of
crude oil the Saudis could easily place
that oil on the international market
remember that we are talking about the
country with the lowest extraction costs
on the planet which means it has a
higher margin than the rest of the
dinosaur juice producers so this time
besides Saving Face with a good client
Riyadh had three other good reasons to
shake hands with Tehran
first of all Saudi Arabia's relations
with the United States are not at their
best and in fact in Riyadh they are
beginning to be weary of the supposed
American protection in 2019 for example
they suffered an attack by two Iranian
drones against their oil infrastructure
without Washington lifting a finger and
that happened with Trump in the white
house because now with Biden relations
are even worse secondly the breakup in
2018 of the joint comprehensive plan of
action that monitored the Iranian
nuclear program got on the nerves of the
Saudi government particularly due to the
lack of Alternatives and Riyadh they are
terrified that Tehran could succeed any
day in getting hold of a nuclear bomb
and that is why they hope that China can
curb these aspirations finally Iran has
pledged to eliminate its support for
Yemen's houthis which will allow Saudi
Arabia to reduce tension in a
long-running conflict that has now
spanned nearly a decade
[Music]
well that's as far as Saudi Arabia is
concerned for its part Iran has its own
goals
[Music]
foreign
firstly to reduce U.S influence in the
region which includes seeking Escape
Routes from International sanctions
secondly to stop the development of the
Abraham agreements between Israel and
the Arab countries you already know that
Israel is the other great enemy of
Iran's Islamic revolution so Iran does
not want under any circumstances that
Riyadh follows in the footsteps of Abu
Dhabi and normalizes its relations with
the Hebrew State and finally they hope
that with this agreement the risk of
military Clash will dissipate Iran
already has enough open fronts but what
about China and why is it so interested
in an issue like this quite simply it is
part of XI jinping's new strategy to
present itself as an influential player
at the international level let's not kid
ourselves the group photograph of the
representatives of these three countries
has been one of China's greatest
diplomatic successes in recent decades
and of course this agreement also calms
tensions in a key region for China's
energy Supply keep in mind that 40 to 50
of all China's energy Imports come from
the Middle East and take note because
the United States buys fewer than 1
million barrels a day from this region
of the world which is equivalent to less
than five percent of its total
consumption in other words a potential
conflict in the Middle East may be
unimportant for the United States but it
would be a nightmare for China now
speaking of the United States what does
Washington think of this agreement many
analysts have suggested that it
represents the end of U.S influence in
this region of the world some even say
that it has been a great diplomatic
failure but is it really so well
let's find out
[Music]
alive and kicking
to what extent does the Tehran Riyadh
deal represent a huge blow to Uncle
Sam's influence how might it affect its
negotiations for preventing Iran from
getting its hands on the nuclear bomb
well watch out because far from what
many have said this agreement might not
particularly be bad for Washington we
can highlight three main reasons you see
yes Saudi Arabia and the United States
are not on the best of terms right now
but things are not really that bad
Riyadh needs and can will continue to
need the U.S military industry basically
because it has New Alternatives what's
more far from what we might think Uncle
Sam continues to strengthen its presence
in the country U.S military is
developing plans to open a new testing
facility in Saudi Arabia not to mention
Mohammed bin Salman's plan to overcome
oil dependence have you heard of the
vision 2030 plan I'm sure you have we'll
keep one thing in mind all these
announcements of Mega projects that the
Saudis make every now and then need one
thing in order to work the participation
of multinationals and American Capital
on the other hand the Americans have
been trying for years to end the war in
Yemen and now after the agreement we
find news stories like this one Saudi
Arabia exit war in Yemen after months of
labored negotiations a peace deal
between Riyadh and the houthi rebels who
have been in Conflict since 2015 is
expected to be announced soon but above
all and perhaps most importantly it is
virtually impossible for this agreement
to have much further to run
taking a deeper look the agreement will
not end tensions between Iranian Shiites
and Saudi were Habi sunnis nor is it
going to end tehran's support for many
Saudi enemies or enemies of Saudi allies
and it certainly does not look like
Tehran will give up its nuclear program
and that is a red line that Riyadh has
marked many times and that brings it
much closer to the United States and
Israel so yes with this agreement China
has managed to strengthen itself in the
eyes of the International Community
Saudi Arabia has dealt another
diplomatic setback to the United States
and Iran's image is in a way whitened
but let's not fool ourselves this
agreement will most likely come to
nothing in the long run and it is
certainly not enough to Herald the end
of Uncle Sam's influence in the Middle
East rather it is a problem but no the
questions are over to you do you think
that China will get both countries to
comply with everything agreed will the
United States respond to this diplomatic
move by China is it possible that China
will curb the Iranian nuclear program
you can leave me your answers in the
comments below and as always don't
forget that here on visualpolitik we
release new videos every week so
subscribe to our Channel and hit the
little bell button down there so you
don't miss any of our updates if you
like this video like it so we know I
hope you enjoyed it all the best and
I'll see you next time
[Music]
foreign